I teach history at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School on February 14th
2018 my school experienced one of the
worst math school shootings in American
history people want to know what we saw
what I felt I don't remember everything
but I do remember I went into crisis
mode mother mode there was no emotion I
lined up the kids I held up a sign so
they could follow me through the hall
just like a fire drill I heard shots
from one direction
luckily we were already moving in the
opposite direction
we made it outside we made it to safety
I called my mother I'm okay I called my
husband I'm okay
and my daughter called my voice cracked
and I knew I had to pull myself together
I sat alone in my thoughts worried about
my colleagues and students we sat there
only understanding that somehow
Valentine's Day we sat there only
understanding that somehow Valentine's
Day had ended up with our baby's dead
and we didn't know what to do next it's
been two months and every day I still
hear the echoes of the pop pop sound of
the gunfire I remember the fearful faces
of my students when we knew it wasn't a
drill still there's no constant emotion
except for flashes of paying grief and
anger triggered by the news or an
insensitive comment or just silence
Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school
lost 17 precious lives on that horrible
day after students asked us the adults
the hardest question how can we stop the
senseless violence this was the most
difficult question I've been asked but
it was not the first time I've been
humbled by a student's question I've
been teaching in the public schools for
33 years so I know you have to admit
what you don't know before you can share
what you do know in fact there's a
method to being an engaged student
teacher citizen first listen closely to
the person asking you a question
second admit your vulnerability admit
what you don't know third do your
homework fourth humbly share your
knowledge I know all about this process
my students ask really thoughtful
questions all the time they're eager to
learn and sometimes they're eager to
prove their smarts and believe me they
know when I have no idea of the answer
so in those instances I say to them
that's a great question let me research
that and get back to you so when my
students asked how do we stop the
senseless violence I listened and
they're not admitted I don't know and
like I always do and I don't know the
answer to one of my questions I began
doing my homework
and as a history teacher I knew I needed
to start with the Second Amendment and
the nrn in case it's been a while since
you've been sitting in a history class
here's what the Second Amendment
actually says a well-read
lated militia being necessary to the
security of a free State the right of
the people to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed meaning the federal
government could not infringe on the
rights of citizens to participate and
well-regulated militias the Second
Amendment was ratified 226 years ago it
was written in that time before the
federal government's armed forces were
among the most powerful in the world and
when state militias reviewed as
necessary to protect the states
fast forward 80 years to 1871 the
American Civil War had ended a few years
prior but a couple of Union officers had
witnessed some pretty shoddy
marksmanship on the battlefield so in an
attempt to prepare their men for any
future conflicts they founded the
National Rifle Association to promote
rifle practice in short the Second
Amendment was written to ensure that our
newly formed and fragile country had
access to organize state militias and
the NRA s original mission was to ensure
future soldiers had good aim someone
could teach an entire course and how the
next 150 years influenced the gun
regulation conversations we're having in
the United States and our interpretation
of the Second Amendment
almost every pivotal moment in our
nation's history in one way or another
influenced how we as a people
manufactured debate regulate and feel
about guns a lot of change has occurred
as a matter of fact it wasn't until 2008
that the Supreme Court ruled for the
first time the Second Amendment protects
an individual right to possess a firearm
unconnected with service in a militia
and to use that arm for traditionally
lawful purposes such as self-defense
within the home within the home this
changeover
time is striking to me because it
reminds us that the interpretation of
the Second Amendment and cultural
attitudes about guns have changed over
time which gives me hope they could
change again
it's an incredibly complex and dynamic
history lesson but it's not the lesson
I'm here to teach today because we don't
have time I'm not talking about time the
time that I have here to stand and speak
I'm talking about the fact we don't have
time to lose
according to the CDC over the last five
years on average each day 96 people are
killed by guns in the United States and
if we don't figure out how to answer my
students question soon one of us could
be next so if the question is how do we
stop this senseless violence the best
way I can think to answer is to look at
multiple choice
you remember multiple-choice questions
in high school don't you let's start
choice a this will end when we hold gun
manufacturers responsible for the
deadliness of their products it might
surprise you to learn that we've
actually thought about this before
between 1998 and 2030 counties and
cities sued gun manufacturers saying
they should make their product safer and
do a better job of tracking where their
products are sold in response
manufacturers argued that they had no
direct liability for how their products
were used they said the stores who sold
the guns and the owners who bought them
were responsible should anything bad
happen in response to this and many
other lawsuits the NRA lobbied for the
passage of the pl CAA
the protection for lawful Commerce and
Arms Act the PLCAA passed with
bipartisan support in 2005 and entrust
gun manufacturers to design guns safely
stores to sell those guns responsibly
and someone to own and use the gun
responsibly and so when seventeen
students and faculty died in my school
no one in this chain will assume
responsibility let's take a look at
another option choice B this will end
when we hold ourselves accountable and
regulate the estimated 300 million guns
available in America yes voting is one
of the best ways to take personal
responsibility for gun violence making
sure that our lawmakers are willing to
pass common-sense gun reform is one of
the most effective ways to get those 300
million guns under control and also gun
owners can take personal initiative if
you own a gun ask yourself do I have an
extra gun I don't need could it fall
into the wrong hands have I attended the
latest training perhaps as a gun owner
you should also ask whether you have
been taking care of your mental health
when it comes to gun violence the mental
health argument falls flat if we don't
acknowledge your own personal
vulnerabilities to mental illness one in
six Americans will struggle with mental
illness if we own a gun we should be
rigorously engaged in the upkeep of our
emotional well-being so we don't pull a
trigger and times of illness otherwise
we should seriously ask ourselves
whether we really have the time and
attention to own a gun perhaps for some
of us it's time to lay down our arms
then we have choice C this will and when
we do a better job of taking care of
each other many social issues affect why
people buy and use guns 62 percent of US
gun fatalities between 2012 and 2016
were suicides
yet we call people maniacs and psychos
shaming them we are creating barriers
for people that need help why are we
embarrassing each other let's make it
easier not harder for people to access
better mental health care what else
sexism racism and poverty effect gun
ownership and gun related fatalities on
average it's estimated that 50 women
were fatally shot each month between
2010 and 2014 due to domestic violence
and women are still dying in their homes
let's empower women and give our young
boys a chance to learn how to work out
their conflicts and emotions with words
not weapons and the Washington Post
reported that last year nearly 1000
people were fatally wounded by on-duty
police officers talk to black lives
matter and the police union about that
we need to tackle this
at the end of the day perhaps people
won't feel the need to buy and use a gun
when they all equally feel safe healthy
respected and cared for all right
discussion time is over it's now time to
answer the question how do we stop the
senseless violence is it choice a choice
B choice C now I know what you're all
thinking
you remember that multiple choice
questions almost never end with just
three possibilities there's always that
fourth choice D all of the above maybe
that's the answer here or maybe all of
the above is too easy and this is not an
easy problem
it requires deep analytical thinking by
all of us so instead I'm asking you to
do your homework write your own choice D
using supporting detail and if you're
not sure where to start look to my
students as role models they are armed
with incredible communication skills and
a sense of citizenship that I find so
inspiring
these are public school kids engaged in
the issue of gun regulation and their
endeavor has moved our hearts and they
shouldn't have to do this on their own
they're asking you they're asking all of
us to get involved this isn't a
spectator sport
so what's the right answer
I don't know listen I'm no gun control
expert I teach the humanities to be
human is to learn and to be part of a
civilization is to share your knowledge
this kind of honest brave and sincere
engagement is what I asked of my
students what I expect of myself as a
teacher and what I demand of you now
every one of you needs to do your
homework and then what humbly share your
knowledge with each other
please teach your family teach your
community your city council your state
legislature teach Congress a lesson
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]